antonio alicorn fears for his future he
is one of the millions of undocumented
immigrants currently residing in the
u.s. Republican presidential frontrunner
Donald Trump has made deporting people
like Antonio a cornerstone of his
platform Antonio believes Trump is
fostering the rise of racism in the u.s.
he and fellow activists are taking to
the streets will they succeed in denying
Trump a win in New York's Republican
primary seeking the spotlight taking to
the streets along with his friends
Antonio alarcón has launched a movement
they carry portraits of undocumented
migrants an estimated 11 million people
live in the US illegally many arrived
decades ago they are accepted have jobs
many even pay taxes today we are
highlighting the stories the
undocumented folks the people who Donald
Thomas are telling that they're illegal
that they're you know papers so we're
sharing the stories we're sharing here
like what are the contributions to the
nation what are the contributions to the
to the city of New York
Antonio was 10 years old when his family
crossed into the u.s. from Mexico he
lives in New York City as an
undocumented migrant though he considers
the u.s. his home he fears he could be
deported at any time I was a free couple
of years ago to be to be staying
undocumented for Athena now I came out
of the shadows and and I'm proud to be
to be a dreamer to be an undocumented
folks undocumented student who
you know who's sharing his story but
also sharing the story of many other
people who still afraid of being
undocumented once the protest is over
Antonio returns to class as an
undocumented immigrant his status is
tenuous but he's permitted to attend
University I want to be a politician in
the future I want to make sure that the
people of my community are being
represented not like mr. Trump oh it's a
politician who is staying a lot of
hateful and racist comments towards our
community I want to make sure that I
represent that community that it's
represented at this moment he will have
to become a citizen to achieve that
lofty goal as it is now he's not allowed
to vote Donald Trump vows to make sure
it stays that way
Trump achieved frontrunner status almost
immediately upon entering the Republican
presidential contest
Antonio believes Trump's success is a
step backwards for the United States
it's just incredible when we think about
the history of the United States it's a
it's pretty much hearing whatever what
what's happening in 1929 or like during
the KKK where the white supremacy was
saying such horrible things about
african-americans it's happening in 2016
now instead of african-americans it's a
variety of Latinos women a Trump
campaign rally in Poughkeepsie New York
it's a Rust Belt city of 30,000 a once
thriving industrial city that's fallen
on hard times unemployment is high and
Trump supporters fear even more jobs
will disappear if illegal immigration
goes unchecked it's an audience
tailor-made for Trump's populist
nationalist message the multi
billionaire sells himself as a man of
the people
it's a message that resonates with this
audience they feel the Washington
bureaucracy has forgotten them the
candidates biggest applause line is his
vow to build a wall on the Mexican
border
outside Trump supporters and opponents
trade verbal fire I feel the people on
both sides of being misleaded by the by
the mass media okay it's not as simple
as Trump is against minorities he's not
he's against illegal immigration a
country without legal borders is not
truly a country we're not opposed to
immigration at all we're just supposed
to the fact that there's no control over
the southern border we are no longer in
economics that stands to hold these
immigrants we used to be at this point I
think that our own people are more
important and I think that of course
immigration is a great thing but we
should be able to you should have to be
stable enough at first with our own
people to go about talk like this angers
Antonio he believes increasing numbers
of Americans are prepared to take a hard
line on immigration and deport illegal
migrants America has been my country for
almost eight years already that's more
than half of my life living in here in
the United States and undocumented folks
are not taking their jobs undocumented
documented people are doing the jobs
that Americans don't want to do
especially farming I don't think I
haven't seen any American doing you know
milking the cow or working on the farm
for 12 hours and getting paid 75 cents
an hour weeks before the New York
primary Antonio and his Konrad's busy
themselves organizing an anti-trump
demonstration one of the many that has
consistently dogged the campaign we
watched along as the group made final
preparations
if the police told you to move move
don't don't delay of half hour or
whatever yeah just be respectful don't
don't say anything bad to the to the
police officer
hoorah let's go my portico is behind me
yes you they make some final phone calls
in hopes of organizing as big a turnout
as possible
it's a 30-minute commute from the
borough of Queens to downtown Manhattan
where Trump has scheduled an afternoon
meeting with Republican leaders
today I don't know what's gonna happen
we're spending more than 5,000 people at
this rally obviously where we're gonna
be protesting very peaceful we don't
want to interrupt anything we just want
to make sure that our voices and the
voices of the community are being heard
I know New York best
I'll put on friends are almost the
demonstration gets underway across the
street from the hotel where the
Republican leadership is meeting
emotions are starting to run high police
and security are out in force and we see
hundreds already probably thousands
people will come
there's people marching from Times
Square all the way here to say that mr.
Trump is not welcome in New York and in
any other city in the country the
protestors represent a broad array of
backgrounds undocumented migrants human
rights activists and african-americans
others are protesting Trump's vowed to
temporarily ban Muslims from traveling
to the US this is not what we are about
and we're going to make sure that he
knows Trump is nowhere to be seen nor
are the members of the Republican
leadership a few protesters tried to
force their way into the hotel
antonio documents the confrontation
but he refrains from getting personally
involved what will happen if they arrest
me probably I will get into jail I don't
know how many days I will be in jail so
we will see I mean for me will be
getting arrest they have a record on my
on my my criminal background and
probably get the porter Antonio is
concerned about his girlfriend Natalia
she's also undocumented but was one of
those who tried to storm the hotel
she's out
like
Natalia hung this anti-trump banner from
a hotel window she's pleased that the
security forces did not interfere we had
a community support at the same time
that I was dropping the banner there
were people doing civil disobedience in
the mezzanine inside of the hotel room
and the ramp of the hotel room in this
corner right here and then I think in
another corner where the limos come so
if you have five actions at the same
time it's really hard for a police
through yet after three energy filled
hours the demonstration is over
Antonio considers that turnout a major
victory they've made a defiant gesture
against the Republican frontrunner as
the polls close in the New York primary
Antonio gathers with friends to watch
the returns huge win for Donald Trump
has scored a landslide victory in his
home state building on his goal of
winning the Republican nomination
Antonio is disappointed but refuses to
give up I think this Donald trum Oldman
has started even before New York we saw
in Chicago sir in Arizona this is just a
momentum that we're building not only
New York but also in other states
we know that Donald Trump will continue
with his rhetoric of inant
anti-immigrant anti-gay anti anti woman
this is just the beginning of all the
effort that we will continue to stop his
his hate towards our communities
antonio makes his way home
determined to press on and build his
movement he and so many others will
continue to hit the streets giving voice
to their opposition to Donald Trump
you